joining us here fresh off of the pro
bowl in las vegas nevada courtesy of
hidden valley ranch of the new orleans
saints
seven time pro bowler cameron jordan
here in the rich eisen show
studio in the flesh good to see you sir
man good to actually be in studio i know
it feels like it feels like we came out
one of those uh infinity wars from the
from the avengers
everybody had a gap two years just a
disappearance of everything else well
you you've always been good to
me this show and i i hope you feel the
same way from from us to you because you
were calling in during the pandemic i
remember one time
it was
two times ago that you waxed brady in
tampa florida okay and you called in
after that sunday night game
and you're like yeah i just got you know
i'm staying in a guest room
right now because i i don't know if i
can i don't want to spread it to my kids
i'm going in and get tested now and
everybody and everybody ended up getting
it when i got it anyway oh my gosh it's
insane
well i'm glad that you are here uh in
the flesh in person absolutely so uh
let's jump into it and then we'll we'll
talk about by the way i've never said
this word uh before uh a chicken wing
waste we'll talk about that in a moment
that wing waste tastes disrespectful
can't have it
you can't have it it happens at every
party but you shouldn't it shouldn't be
allowed we can't have it we'll talk
about it we'll put a pin in that uh and
then we'll remove the pin later on so
did you get any sense from sean payton
throughout the year that uh this could
be the end of the ride no i mean we're
so locked in on on winning and or we
went on like this we're going like a
five or six
game losing streak which is the longest
losing streak i think i've had in my
career right um
we were so focused on getting out the
hole fighting into a playoff spot at
least play off contention which we ended
up being what at the very end of the
season it lasted to what
even after after we beat the falcons you
know we went to the locker room thinking
like hey we got a chance at this yeah
and then we didn't so did you put the
game on yeah absolutely it was all in
the locker room we were watching we were
watching uh
you know the the niners beat the rams
and i said
that was it well i said you know how
hard is to be the third team you know a
team of the third time so right you know
um
sucks for us but
this is probably the first time in five
years we hadn't been to the playoffs
it's a weird feeling not being in the
playoffs i bet so like you know like the
browns know this feeling well so they're
just like hey look at you you know look
at us we won five games this year or
nine games you know whatever it is
what's with the broadside on the on the
bronze where did that come from
you know you just felt like it just felt
felt good about it okay it rolled it
roll off easy okay very good like
objects about to say as if the browns
fans don't have enough crap it's as if
they don't have enough problems right
now odell's in the super bowl the
bengals are in the super bowl
right i mean i don't know if you saw
jarvis landry popped in on odell's media
session yesterday such a dog saying how
much i love you and we're rooting for
you and i'm brown's friends everybody's
sitting there sitting here and by the
way it got worse today i don't know if
you heard can i act like twitter and be
like if jarvis is congratulating obj's
he to the rams as well
it got it got worse today the oscar
nominations came out i know you've been
running around uh best documentary
director odell beckham senior
got an oscar nomination for a movie
called my son was open it's really crazy
he put that video no i'm just kidding
obj sorry brockman
my son was open it was a great day
it's the first oscar animation for any
dad who put a documentary on twitter
it's important remember he put all those
videos i saw
i saw cause i saw the narrative it was
you know obj's a problem or bj you know
and i like it see you're very good at
what you do cameron jordan because here
i am trying to delve about your coach
and now you just got me on a tangent
about the browns you're good man i just
caught myself so shadow champagne yeah
well done yeah so uh
when you i know you kind of you know
tapped out for the first 24 48 because
we we rang your phone up to see if you
want to come on and talk about it what
did you what conversation can you share
that twitter i went uh social media dark
you did uh i had i had to figure out my
feelings first well what i was like how
do you feel about it i don't know it's
like it's like when you you know when
your wife asks you how do you how do you
like the new couch
i don't know haven't sat in it it looked
good i don't know what you feel about
the couch
because there's like a price point that
comes into it that makes you feel a
certain type of way how much did we
spend on this couch okay maybe i like it
there are a lot of factors that go in
exactly so there's a lot of factors
heading to you know my my head coach the
only head coach i've had in the nfl you
know taking the reprieve or sabbatical
or whatever he's going to call it right
because he said he didn't say he was
done coaching right in fact the opposite
he said i look forward to coaching again
right so
i was like i don't know how i feel about
this so so you're saying he's done with
me
you know um took it personal and then i
was like look as a business decision
he's getting up 16 years of his life to
the saints and i mean you know you go
you know the amount of work that goes
into being a head coach i mean i've seen
him you know have the cot in the room uh
you know he's spending multiple days
there i know how uh how
intuitive his offense drew everybody was
uh to tweaking the machine that was the
new orleans saints offense for so many
years right um that takes a toll and so
you know if you take you take some time
off do what you got to do
i understand that
as a person on outside the walls inside
the walls i'm like why are you going to
leave now
we've been knocking on the door of the
playoffs every year and even in this
tumultuous year that we've had being
displaced to dallas at starting like 50
what 58 starters 53 starters the 58 i'm
gonna say just because it's a bigger
number you know um
going through four different
quarterbacks this year um and still
having
a shot at the playoffs at the end of the
year and in ending in the positive um
what do we go nine and eight yeah i mean
and that's you know
teams previous to this you've seen get
into playoffs with the losing record
this year it's like we're still knocking
we're still here and for you you know
for sean to step down i say look this
got to be bigger than just just football
right now so good for him we've got we
just signed uh d.a that's right so you
decided to dc is now the agency exactly
it's weird timing because it didn't they
just
sean just had uh had a movie release
right about his stint taking time off i
thought that was just you know
yeah supposed to be a movie the
theatrics acting well this could be
setting up the sequel you took that
seriously you could be setting up the
sequel of taking another year you know
what i mean like you could be doing
something like that exactly but dennis
allen is somebody who's been an uh head
coach before and now uh so the
continuity i would imagine is
is good they'll say for sure that um
immediately once i saw it i texted d.a i
immediately got a text back you know i
took sean and i didn't get immediate
text back it's crazy
the reason for that is he's still
talking from his press conference
i i saw him i saw he hasn't responded
yet no um no i'm just kidding um you
know
we're talking you know just talking to
d.a super excited for him i think you
know he's had a stint with the raiders
we don't hold that against him clearly
nice and then uh you know
him him being in the black and gold just
fits well if it's right hopefully
cameron jordan here uh on the rich eisen
show how do you see super bowl 56 going
[Music]
nothing but love for for obj i've got
nothing to love for you know aaron
donald and von miller especially vaughn
miller draft class 2011 greatest draft
class ever um
you know there's that's just facts at
this point our first round is
untouchable
um and then of course you know on the
other side we've got trey henderson von
bell eli apple all i'll play with the
black and gold and trey hayden is my dog
you know and and the stellar year he's
put together it's still the two years
he's put together um
i'm split we've got a little we've got a
little joe boro action which has some
lsu connection
via ohio state
i'll be we'll take it
i mean
if i had to go one way i
i would go uh who i like on defense best
and that is man the defense
who is that we gotta go if i'll say
aaron donald right i mean as much as you
say everything else
can't you ever keep i said you know last
game i said you can't ever count von
miller and aaron donald out but also joe
burrow been sacked nine times and he's
got a young enough body where he's just
bouncing off the turf getting up and
still throwing them them dime pieces
i mean what is that like for a defender
that puts somebody on teammates put put
somebody on their ass nine times and he
just keeps getting up and keeps throwing
eventually eventually the door gotta
break down but it's not it won't be this
year
clearly you know if
eight nine years from now
probably okay so uh who's going to win
the game cameron oh i see you're trying
to get that out of me
if it's up to me there is no winner and
we just have to postpone it's not up to
you
it's up to the football gods that's not
another covered year no no it's up to
you i'm gonna leave it up to the uh the
football higher powers to figure that
one out i'm gonna say i i assume
that there will be a winner and a loser
oh my god what about points do you think
there's gonna be a lot of points
no hey i'm here for a great defensive
game
i do think i do think it might be a 30
34 7 situation thirty four
wow
if i'm gonna if i'm gonna be honest i'm
looking forward to somebody just putting
up way more points than the next oh
interesting yeah like something like the
hometown i mean
not not saying who oh he just why won't
you do it i mean because i like chase i
like t higgins i mean i like
i mean i like that
personally i think it's very well i
think i think clearly there's an
advantage to the offensive line versus
they're all you know
the line versus bengals offensive line
and i think clearly you have a a
possibility a large one a great one of
being successful in being part of the
paparazzi once you want to hang them up
right right let's go let's just
broadcast boot camp on the rich eyes and
show cameron jordan who would like and
they have to understand this is nothing
personal you were giving your
professional opinion you are cameron
freaking jordan
the only professional opinion i have
right now is how did you get best dad
ever i've got four
children
that i think adore me
all right
and i have the sign you don't
you could always use the excuse with
anybody you do me like that on the rich
eisen show by picking against me the
super bowl you could say i was wearing a
chicken wing waist
jacket okay from hidden valley ranch you
could say that i've never done this
before so go for it who wins super bowl
56
the one who doesn't waste the most wings
that's ridiculous
interesting you know i'm just saying
the guys with the full stomach going to
have the protein necessary to go ahead
and compete at the highest level the
guys who are you know
not eating their wings the right way
drums or flats who's hoisting this
trophy by the way have you noticed the
trophy sitting here i saw that i saw
that how about that for flex i mean
if anybody could pull it off it would be
rich either thank you sir
who is who is lifting this trophy
between the two of them
oh between the two of us no
the trophy that is sitting in between us
which team puts their fingerprints on it
the cincinnati bengals
the one with the uh mvp of the game and
then the head coach obviously you know
but is the mvp like joe burrow or
matthew stafford
i'm biased
miller okay
i'm thinking a.d von miller trey
hendrickson or vaughn bill tweet it out
cameron jordan thinks the rams win super
bowl 56 and a blow out and right aaron
donald correct the winning team i just
heard all of them
you know uh when the but wouldn't the
winning and losing team have a short
drive home because they got like they
probably got to stay the night right did
the winning team sleep in their own bed
okay so the winning team would probably
sleep in their own beds because they'll
still be busy partying
for this weekend um there's a great psa
that you've shot with hidden valley
ranch post a picture of video of your
wings and ranch with the hashtag of
stopwingwaste hashtag contest and folks
can win a year's supply of wings whoa
autographed items by you and some great
game day swag i'm just saying look while
you're eating your wings there's gonna
be wings at every super bowl party while
you're eating your wings go ahead you
know tag it post it right hit him with
the hashtag stopwingwaste okay hashtag
contest and if i did that would you
predict the super bowl for me on live
rich eisen show if i actually promised i
would do that absolutely you know
when i see it i can i can retweet out
who i think is going to win okay because
we both know you know i don't have wings
around to make that happen right now i'm
very smart i say look you're in la you
know the air hits different everybody's
going half vegan like you know i don't i
don't know i don't know what that has to
do with us but we need those wings we
need we need the uh the sauce dripping
you know you got to get the good dipping
bite you got to get a good you know
little uh okay
i'm just saying there's multiple
techniques go check it out on you know
caww.org
very good um before i let you go um
cameron jordan here on the rich eisen
show you sir are fresh back from the pro
bowl you know fans think that the game
kind of lacked what we say uh
yeah
what do you mean look i've heard
feedback but i had the time of my life
rushing with some of the best defensive
linemen in the game i don't know what
happens behind me but i do know i've you
know they say we're supposed to run four
straight they were stunts being played i
i had the i had the uh opportunity run
beside uh you know run games with brian
burns
um
with uh sweat with alan i mean
i'm over here
big vida veya i didn't realize how big
beautiful it was so i feel like i said
so you don't think that the game needs
any sort of tinkering or changing i'll
leave that to the higher ups to to mess
up a good thing look i was having i was
having a blast
now i think the lions were out there
getting it you were
i mean did you did you not watch the
d-line play
there was a whole load front at one
point in time there was chandler jones
robert queen me
and and burns on the field at the same
time
nascar package crazy well that's it is
crazy but that's why you know uh you
could hurt somebody and that's why you
know you could see sometimes that
they're really bad thing
i know more i mean
the pro bowl's never been about hitting
and it's never been about that sort of
thing so i don't know
but people think that it you know dion
put out a tweet saying that you know
guys
aren't coaching i know coach prime put
out a tweets talking about the game has
changed since he played in the pro bowl
back and forth gotten faster
stronger more physical you can't you
can't hit up top you can't you know like
you know there's a lot of things you
can't do back in his day mm-hmm his day
that
yeah
many many many many
okay so you don't think anything needs
to be done to change the pro bowl
cameron jordan seven time pro bowler
i mean could it go back to hawaii
[Laughter]
see didn't i tell this is what happens
when you ask somebody in the game what
about what about like the bahamas
australia yeah let's change it up like
you put pressure on the players where
they have to fly the families out and
then like you like we talked about
earlier you either break even or you
don't exactly i'm telling you this is
the reality of it and let's go to puerto
rico
you want to figure we could put it or
put everything in a hat and figure it
out no doubt just like just like spin
the globe like bring football to
germany so
cameron jordan cameron jordan says the
following uh that uh just to wrap it all
up um pro bowl doesn't need to be
changed
uh wondered why his coach was leaving
but then figured it out that
everything's cool check out check out
caw.org
exactly that's it okay uh hidden valley
ranch check out uh basically take a
picture of your v or video of your wings
and ranch with the hashtag of stop wing
waste and hash contest snap it tag it
post it okay you know the deal big
hashtag you can win a year's supply of
wings another thing but i'm gonna start
bringing it back and the other thing is
i think the rams win by three touchdowns
super bowl
yeah right did i get it
um i know there's going to be a lot of
defensive sides and or
and or
that two teams win by a blowout is super
allowed to be a tie we parlay it till
next year and then i get two trophies
let's work on that we'll workshop that
thanks thanks for coming by cameron
jordan of the new orleans saints at
camjordan94 on twitter and instagram hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here